bref sur le point sur ce qu'ils aiment
ou n'aiment pas les shadoks on peut pas
uniquement se contenter du corps y est
il faut également interrogé les gens les
shadoks en principe ne plaisent pas dit
on aux gens sérieux et il n'y a rien de
plus sérieux qu'un polytechnicien c'est
pourquoi ce soir vous allez avoir la vie
des jeunes polytechniciens à notre
époque caractérisée par l'évolution
d'une prospective résolument
construction analystes je trouve anormal
que la télévision qui a un potentiel
intrinsèque de vecteurs culturels
sa baisse a diffusé un feuilleton comme
les shadoks qui est dénué absolument de
tout substratum formaliste
c'est vrai ça voulait tout à fait à
l'aise quand il s'agit de shadocks
sommes devant notre poste de télévision
ça nous rappelle déjà les mathématiques
on ne sort pas de notre monde
alain je crois que dans les chais
d'ajustement ya l'idée de base mais
après ça l'auteur en tire toutes les
conclusions logiques enfin j'en voudrais
pour exemple la façon dont les chevilles
cherche le cosmo gaulle ils ne peuvent
pas l'extraire du sol pourquoi parce que
leur planète est en place il creuse des
trous cela fera une passoire
d'ailleurs je sais d'une remise en
question et là effectivement c'est bien
ces bruits en ce sens on peut considérer
que c'est les shadoks ça nous rappelle
la première démarche l'enjeu c'est ça
oui nous sentons tout à fait à l'aise
quand nous voyons les shadoks parce que
nous sommes des mathématiciens ce qui
nous intéresse
la plupart du temps c'est la recherche
la recherche imaginative un certain
nombre de solutions laisse tourner deux
concepts que nous imaginons et on en
tire des tués conclusion logique qui
forcément arrive à un résultat absurde
qui est comique de là que vient le
commune des chefs-d'oeuvre
nous devons avoir fondamentalement la
signification
or cette signification est absente et
d'autre part à mon avis et d'autre part
la personnalisation je ne la comprends
pas évidemment c'est une question de
point de vue
certains pensent pas remuer camarades en
particulier que les shadoks représente
certains peuples élégie mise d'autre ne
sais pas si vous êtes d'accord avec ce
monsieur
voici je crois que l'egypte pourrait
très bien symboliser le petit français
futé malins qui qui fait son petit truc
tout seul et qui arrive à rouler si on
veut les shadoks qui ont bloqué un peu
la grosse méthode systématique qui font
des essais tous les jours
l'école polytechnique compte parmi ses
anciens élèves de très grands noms foch
joffre gay lussac
est-ce qu'ils auraient aimé les shadoks